okay so three tips to make this word
sound more natural
one when you say the japanese
la sound
don't round or protrude your lips at the
beginning of the sound if i say
wake up or just wake in english and i
say it slowly in a natural way however
you can see that my lips are
significantly rounded and protruded
again as in
wake up wake up wake up
rounded and protruded lips this doesn't
happen in the japanese w sound it
happens in the english sound but not in
the japanese w sound so if i just say
just the beginning just this sound i say
my lips are essentially neutral so
that's tip number one don't round your
lips in the japanese w tip number two is
that this word should this word should
be said in a more or less flat manner it
doesn't have an accent in the middle of
the word so it's not
but
it's more or less flat if you're native
english speaker you're going to have the
tendency to want to put an accent in the
middle but it doesn't have an accent try
and say it like a robot
so that's tip number two and then tip
number three is that even if you are
saying this word in a more or less flat
manner if you're a native english
speaker you're going to have the
tendency to want to not clearly
articulate the first vowel the first
vowel in this word isn't
right it's this sound right if you're
native english speaker you're going to
probably unconsciously want to say uh
uh kind of as in
if i say this word again in like a
really stereotypical really unnatural
foreigner way then i can say
watashi
watashi notice again how the first vowel
isn't
ah but it's
uh watashi
and this is what's known as vowel
reduction it's something that we kind of
unconsciously do in english but it
doesn't occur in the same way in
japanese that it does in english so try
and be aware of that and try and clearly
articulate that first vowel as well and
this is actually true for the more
colloquial form of this word as well in
which the w is dropped altogether you
would never say
you would just say
now again that if i'm saying it and
after i've explained it you would
probably think no one would ever say it
like that but this is actually fairly
common if you're not conscious of it you
want to clearly articulate the first
vowel whether you're dropping the w
as some female speakers do or not okay
so again the three tips are one don't
round your lips or protrude them in the
japanese w two don't say the word with
an accent in the middle and then three
clearly articulate that first vowel it's
not
okay hope that was useful for those that
don't know i teach japanese
pronunciation and pitch accent on my
patreon linked below best of luck with
your future japanese studies and see you
guys again soon